qu'est-ce qu'il faut acheter cette année
pour Noël les jeux vidéo ça stimule
c'est les jeux de baston surtout du
genre Street Fighter 2 Mortal
Kombat une récente enquête montre que
les petits Français sont les plus gâtés
d'Europe on leur offre plus de jouets
qu'aux enfants allemands anglais ou
italien mais que leur offrir s'ils ont
oublié d'écrire et de vous envoyer la
lettre ou d'envoyer la lettre au Père
Noël quelles sont les grandes tendances
de la vente des jouets cette année
reportage marieor
bon
cher petit papa Noël comme beaucoup de
mes copains je voudrais des cassettes de
jeux vidéo et le pistolet qui va avec je
voudrais aussi trois peluches immenses
et des voitures de collection j'espère
que tu as entendu ma liste de Noël
martial la lettre au Père Noël de
Martial reflète assez justement les
désirs des enfants pour ce Noël 91 on
note un véritable rush sur les jeux
vidéos une tendance qui existait depuis
déjà 2 ans mais qui atteint cette année
un niveau sans
précédent ce sont tous les jeux vidéos
avec les consoles les game boys toutes
toutes ces cassettes où les gens où les
les enfants filles ou garçons peuvent
jouer seul ou à plusieurs c'est réservé
aux enfants de quel âge disons aux
enfants entre 8 et 13 ans 14 ans des
adultes aussi vous savez et ça
représente beaucoup pour vous ça va
représenter c'est probablement 30 % de
notre chiff d'affaires de fin d'année
tout de suite après les jeux vidéos les
Barbies jouets que l'on qualifie de
classique mais dont le succès ne tarie
pas actuellement en France une poupée
Barbie est vendue toutes les 10 secondes
les peluches ont également une place
importante dans le cœur des enfants
d'autant plus que le choix est vaste
mais la surprise de cette année ce sont
les petites voitures de collection qui
pour ce Noël se refont une jeunesse les
enfants retrouvent avec elle et avec les
soldats de plomb le goût pour les jouets
de qualité les jouets éternels qu'est-ce
qu'il faut acheter cette année pour Noël
des jeux vidéos ça stimule puis après
l'école c'est ça détend c'est quoi la
tendance dans les jeux vidéos
c'est les jeux de baston surtout du
genre Street Fighter 2 Mortal Kombat il
devait passer à Noël 93 un peu tristeou
NAET mais il semble bien qu'on ait vendu
la peau des jeux vidéo un peu
prématurément cette année encore maître
Sega et Super Mario occuperont le haut
de la hôte du Père Noël la Formule 1 du
jouet 500 francs la cassette en moyenne
a encore la côte tous les rayons jeux
vidéo des grands magasins font en
moyenne 30 m de long la culture vidéo
c'est plus fort que les parents ils
achètent malheureusement c'est plus
l'époque des jouets en bois et cetera
moi je voudrais bien mais euh ce qui lui
fait plaisir et ce qui le passionne
euh beaucoup d'heures même par jour
c'est ça ce sont les jeux vidéos vous
êtes pas un peu perdu vous dans ces jeux
vidéos complètement je suis d'ailleurs
il a 7 ans c'est lui qui parle au
vendeur je je sais pas techniquement ce
qu'il veut demander euh j'essaie de
suivre pour pas être complètement comme
on dit entre guillemets largué mais
j'avoue que c'est difficile c'est tiré
d'un dessin animé qui passe en ce moment
à la télé même si le père Noël cette
année encore sera japonais il faut
pourtant bien se rendre à l'évidence les
jeux vidéos se sont banalisés ils font
partie de l'univers familial trois
enfants de moins de 15 ans sur 4
possèdent aujourd'hui une console il
faut qu'il vienne de bonne heure sont
rentrés dans les jeux courants dans les
basiques ça fait partie d'une famille
courante mais plus d'une famille de mode
non non ils sont pas démodés non plus
mais ils font par
du milieu du jouet comme font partie la
poupée la peluche les jeux de premier
âge c'est une famille de plus du coup
les chefs de la famille vidéo multiplie
les nouveaux titres et appelle au
secours le progrès technologique le
compact disque est arrivé chez Sega la
définition de l'image est proche du
cinéma et le joueur devient
[Musique]
acteur bonne nouvelle malgré tout pour
les vidéoob les jeux de société
reviennent à la mode un mortal combat
peut s'engager entre le neuf et le VI
à J-1 c'est le roche sur les jouets et
qu'on le veuille ou pas qu'il croit au
Père Noël ou non les enfants ont déjà
fait leur choix j'ai Spiderman comme
déguisement je sais pas lequel choisir
et comme déguisement et puis j'ai aussi
le personnage de Spider-Man que je vais
commander un ordinateur et un agenda
électronique et un dictionnaire
électronique pour les tout petits pas de
changement par rapport à l'an passé
audelà les poupées pour les fill et les
jouets inspirés des dessins animés pour
les garçons sont toujours à la mode mais
les jeux éducatifs font un retour en
force on vaend beaucoup moins de jeux
vidéo et une grosse augmentation par
contre dans les jeux dans tous les
ordinateurs éducatifs quant à ma
préférence Jean-Pierre un robot qui sert
le café au lit bonjour Jean-Pierre je
m'appelle Émilio je suis la dernière
nouveauté des jouer cette année pour
Noël alors si vous êtes généreux vous
pourrez l'offrir à Jean-François garcier
c'est génial au top du parade cette
année le jeu vidéo avec ses nouvelles
consoles Saturn et Sega il fait des
ravages auprès des garçons de 8 à 12
ans c'est un pass c'est
bien on sait pas quoi faire on s'ennuie
pas Batman surtout ses accessoires
Batmobile vaisseau gadget font la joie
de collectionneur préco j'aime bien les
Batman parce que je les
collectionne côté fille Barbie reste la
préférée même s'il n'y a pas eu de
nouveauté cette année ses accessoires et
sa coquetterie font toujours craquer
autre succès chez les filles donc en jeu
de société pour les filles c'est le
téléphone secret qui marche le mieux
donc c'est un jeu de société où il faut
découvrir son admirateur moi qu'est-ce
que j'ai mis sur ma liste au Père Noël
tu as mis tellement de choses il m'a dit
je voudrait des jeux de société pour
jouer avec mes copains il a commandé
donc le tabou le
Mastermind un jeu qui s'appelle réveil
papa un jeu de société qu'un petit
copain a et qu' a adore quand il va chez
lui il arrête pas de jouer à ça les jeux
de société et les jeux éducatifs sont le
grand succès de ce Noël 95 qu'il soit
manuel ou électronique les enfants
seraient donc devenus sérieux
raisonnables et studieux en fait ils
expriment souvent le désir de leurs
parents mais rassurons-nous au fond les
petits garçons rêvent toujours de
voiture de moto un jouet qui est leur
rêve et qu'ils n'auront pas parce que
c'est une question de place et puis
c'est vrai que ça revient cher c'est les
motos électriques les voitures
électriques mais il m'en reparle chaque
année de ces jouets là et bon on a pas
la place d'avoir quelque chose comme ça
à la maison les filles adorent toujours
Barbie les garçons préfèrent po Rangers
mais globalement ils délaissent les
gadgets et choisissent des valeurs sûres
cette année la mode tient plus du
classique poupée Corolle préféré au
Barbie au profil jugé trop américain les
peluches en masse qui font un retour en
force chez les petits et leurs parents
mais aussi les jouets utile ou sportif
électronique ou initiatique bref chaque
année c'est la même histoire quand il
s'agit de leurs enfant enfant les
parents oublient la crise le reste de la
famille aussi sur les 1800 francs de
cadeaux que reçoit en moyenne chaque
enfant dans l'année il encumule 1500
pour Noël et avec l'âge le jouet bien
sûr se sophistique ou devient un objet à
la mode si les jeux vidéos se portent
encore très bien le chic du chic en
cette saison c'est le de rou simple au
toutterrain vendu par milliers
d'exemplaires en alu ou un fibre de
carbone pour les esètes la VTT tout ça
va relancer je pense pu les petits ont
ça écoutez vousmême vous avez un tri
vousmême vous avez un vélo alors
voyez-vous ça continue la tradition le
millésim 96 en matière de jouet fut un
bon cru même si la dépense moyenne par
objet dépassait sensiblement les 300
francs le fameux maman ta pas 100 balle
aura donc vécu le style et
l'enthousiasme ne trompe pas le père
Noël est passé par là au moment de la
promenade digestive les enfants
étraînent la démarche souvent mal assuré
des rollleurs flambant neuf euh non
c'est pas trops difficile c'est tombé
déjà euh oui trois fois des enfants pas
seulement car dans certaines familles
les parents ont reçu le même cadeau que
leurs progéniture une façon peut-être de
se prouver qu'ils ont su rester jeunes
il paraît que ce genre de jouet aide les
enfants à canaliser leur agressivité ça
c'est ce que pensent les psychiatres en
tout cas une chose est sûre les enfants
adorent ils aiment et aimeront encore
plus cette année tout ce qui rappelle
leur héros de film ou de dessin animés
préférés le Z qui veut dire Zoro sera
sur toutes les lettres destin au Père
Noël et les petites filles ne rateront
sûrement pas les poupées mannequins à
l'effigie de leur boys band favorie Père
Noël débordéit comme chaque année il a
déjà reçu des tonnes de lettres voyons
avec Laurent Delsol et Francis Maresco
qu'il connaissent bien quelles sont
leurs préférences pour ce dernier Noël
des années 1000 pardon madame il vous
reste des furbies ah pour aujourd'hui
j'ai tout vendu monsieur j'en ai plus un
seul il me reste que celui-ci je reçois
demain voici la star des stars le furbi
c'est la version peluche de feu tamagi
et tout comme lui il apprend à parler
dormir et
manger et voici le cadeau phare pour les
garçons un peu plus grands qui veulent
déjà imiter papa les voitures
radioommandé traversent les années et
deviennent de plus en plus énervés les
petits enfants je crois qu'il seront
très heureux avec
ça c'est le but je crois c'est pas et
les parents avec le bruit parents par MO
du côté jeune demoiselle c'est encore et
toujours cette indétronnable poupée qui
crêpe le chignon aux autres jouets ce
sont les accessoires plébicités par la
publicité qui se vendent en l'occurrence
pour cette année cette voiture
cabriolete la poupée c'est la valeur
sûre bref à la veille de l'an 2000 ce ne
sont pas les jouets intergalactiques qui
sont en orbite en dehors de quelques
épisphénomènes médiatiques par exemple
comme Star Wars ou d'autres phénomènes
comme Tarzan ou de la publicité
télévisuelle qui en fait vont cibler
certains produits en particulier le gros
de notre chiffre d'affaires
effectivement est consé par des jouets
plutôt
traditionnels les jouets traditionnels
se vendent tellement bien que dans ce
grand magasin tout un espace leur est
désormais
[Musique]
consacré